Một môn tháng ba, tò hồ về Ivan, Iris, Dana, Wikers, Rheal & Ka, đã bị tấn công bằng tò ngâm.
Sà đến một trong lệ một người mất em và bệnh mấy tảng người thương.
Wikers, Rheal & Ka, Ví Chutai Hoarach, Chupiet,
Bà miệ ai thì thu được cứ vật dưa vào bệnh viện Thara, PGR, tại gale,
Chúng kì có hả đồng cố hộ và năng tiếp sĩnh E ngoài vùng lãnh Hải, Rheal & Ka.
Wuy nhân vô vật hiện chứ đoam sáu như dễn sát chứ bối cảnh.
Súng đoam con sử dưới miếng Israel và Ivan đang liều thang.
Bộ tức lãnh Trung tâm Mỹ Sên Còn Chúa Đau Thung Báo đã pháu yên mùi bẩy tong Hải Quân Yeran,
Bàu ông, Tong Anh, kể tức ý trên dịch không kích bắt đầu vào ngày 2020.
Các đoàn tấn công lãnh nhà bẩy ra đã kiến lãnh của Hồ Hồn Ál y Kê Me Ngay,
không nhiều con chức cơm khuyệt mặt.
Chúc khi Té Rán đáp trả măng tư luar và URV,
nhằm vợ Israel và cân cố Mỹ tại vùng vệ bộ việc tòi ra bị tấn công ngoài khơi ảnh đự dương,
chứ thấy xung đột đăng mử dọng gióng hỏi Trung đông.